With party funding,
are you the a t m,
are you directly funded,
uh, by private business
or you've got your own funding model
which maybe is through the church?
How are you getting money for campaigning?
Uh, are you getting it from
the one that government allocates to parties?
Uh, so that you,
you don't fall trap
to the same thing that you were saying.
It's a problem.
We are funded by our members.
It is our members who contribute towards our,
um, our programs.
Even now we
at the manifesto, even,
even in the manifesto,
um, on the Friday with the Galardina
fundraising Galardina.
Okay. All of the,
we actually called for people to pledge
all of the people that pledged there,
um, you know, the,
the people that fund our campaign.
The reason why,
um, you know,
your answer, your, your,
the answer to your question by is enough.
You can check the amount of posters we have as a party
versus these parties that are well funded.
Check how we do not have,
we do not pass people to our stadiums.
If, you know, if,
if we had money to pass people to our stadium,
we could even fill up F
N B and Orlando Stadium at the same time.